benvenuti questo nuovissimo oggi
parleremo di cibo in particolare volevo
darvi dei piccoli consigli per non
ingrassare durante le feste durante le
vacanze di natale che come sappiamo
rappresenta il periodo dell'anno nel
quale ci sentiamo un pochino più deboli
di fronte a tutte le delicatezze
culinarie che i nostri occhi vedranno
quindi mi avete chiesto ma tu marina
come come farai durante le vacanze
sceglierai a qualsiasi ciba qualsiasi
pietanza che ti faccia gola oppure
cercherai di selezionare di trattenere
insomma questi istinti l'ingordigia
pesantissimi per questo motivo ho deciso
insomma di farci un video per dare
piccoli consigli che chiaramente insomma
partono da bene senso non non sono una
nutrizionista però sono le regole
diciamo che seguo io quindi è come se da
mika amici vi dicessi io farei così io
farei così guardiamo subito dal primo
consiglio che mi sento di darvi allora
la parola chiave pianificazione
pianificare cioè sapete che il 24 sera
avete la cena sapete che il 25 france
avete il pranzo coi parenti sapete che
il 31 andrete al cenone con gli amici e
ci sarà un sacco da mangiare benissimo
disegnate il calendario che quelli da te
li potete concedervi qualcosina in più
durante tutti gli altri giorni
dovrete invece mantenere una dieta sana
ed equilibrata cioè non vuol dire stare
a digiuno vuol dire aperture vuol dire
proteine vuol dire magari evitare i
carboidrati in modo tale che arriviate
ai vostri eventi
culinarie gastronomici e con la
possibilità di cedere un pochino di
concedervi qualcosa in più è soltanto
questione di equilibrio e controllo non
dovete assolutamente pensare che se
volete mantenere la linea dovete
digiunare a natale sbagliatissimo è una
volta sola il natale durante l'anno
quindi potete assolutamente godervi
vostri grazie mister cene con la
famiglia e con gli amici senza aver
paura di mangiare troppo l'importante
come vi ho detto e dosare le cose quindi
equilibrio e controllo il secondo
consiglio che voglio darvi è quello di
non abbandonare del tutto l'attività
fisica perché chiaramente se mangiare di
più se non fate movimento e non fate
attività fisica è più facile che insomma
prendiate qualche chiletto in più ora
attività fisica non vuol dire per forza
mettersi il soggiorno con la famiglia
che ci guarda fare scuola fai workout no
potete benissimo fare delle dei cicli
molto più brevi di 5 10 minuti di
attività intensa anche se anche una
corsetta e al parco una corsetta sul
lungomare vi serve per bruciare le
calorie che insomma avete assunto e per
attivare il metabolismo che un attimino
si era seduto con questi giorni di
inattività
ricordatevi che non per forza stare in
famiglia significa stare alla stessa
tavola ad abbuffarsi vuol dire anche
magari uso più le del tempo che abbiamo
a disposizione per stare con loro per
stare con gli amici che non vediamo mai
durante l'anno per fare attività insieme
magari
delle attività una risposta ci
coinvolgono magari fare una passeggiata
per andare a fare delle spese per
accompagnarla non ha scaricato a
prendere le ultime cose che servono
insomma qualsiasi cosa che sia movimento
che merita in movimento appunto il
nostro metabolismo e ci faccia bruciare
tante calorie terzo consiglio è
sicuramente fate attenzione a quello che
vedete perché se mangiamo di più e
vediamo biancolli c
chiaramente prendiamo anche più kg
quindi fondamentale avere tantissima
acqua come sempre d'altronde è anche
notari dopo le cene dopo i passi un po
più impegnativi un bel the verde una
bella camomilla una bella tisana detox
insomma tutto quello che può aiutarci a
depurare l'organismo se chiaramente
essendo insomma un periodo festivo
volete concedervi qualche bicchiere di
alcolici ecco io opterei per o in rosso
o champagne del consiglio magari
invitare superalcolici sapete quelli
belli supercalorici super zuccherati
super cremosi ecco quelli magari li
eviterei se comunque volete fare uno
strappo alla regola e bevi voi 23
superalcolici
fate non però come dicevamo del primo
punto sempre pianificandolo cioè
a cena ho mangiato tanto magari superare
fuori colore vivido
sono tre giorni che mangio bene
verdura proprio in eccetera la sera vado
parlare con gli amici mi prendono
alcolico sempre chiaramente equilibrio e
controllo quanto consiglio super super
super importante è non saltare i passi è
un consiglio che vale tutto l'anno
a maggior ragione durante le feste
perché se chiaramente magari risvegliate
tardi non fate colazione magari uscite
subito e quindi non fate pranzo arrivati
a cena che volete sbranarli tutta la
famiglia
ecco forse avete sbagliato è
fondamentale capire cosa avete veramente
voglia di mangiare nel senso se
chiaramente a natale solo 20.000
pietanze selezionate quelle non dico che
devo essere forza dietetiche però quelle
che ti piace ai due quelle che vista
siano non sforate non superate il limite
della costa fame soltanto perché è
natale avete tutto cibo lì davanti non è
una scusa per abbuffarsi spesso infatti
durante queste cene così pranzi
familiari di base mangiamo spesso tanto
pè sbagliatissimo quindi cercate di
capire qual è il vostro limite e non su
peraltro non mangiate il tanto bel
quinto consigli o molto breve ma molto
importante è non mangiare tra un pasto e
l'altro questa regola vale sempre se non
volete prendere chili
per quanto riguarda il natale se
chiaramente a pranzo quando il pranzo
della nonna concetta a cena è il pranzo
dalla nonna regina e a merenda vi
mangiate quello che ha cucinato la mamma
il giorno prima ecco forse state
sbagliando qualcosa non mangiate tra un
pasto e l'altro il sesso vini consiglio
è non mangiare pane o almeno provarci
magari
vi consiglio di sostituire il pane al
pane integrale a fare anzi insomma a
tutti quei tipi di pane che non
apportano così tante così tanti
carboidrati e quindi calorie di cui
sinceramente natale non abbiamo bisogno
settimo ed ultimo consiglio è
importantissimo ragazzi le ragazze non
impari cativi assolutamente non succede
nulla se dopo il cenone di natale vi
sentite gonfissimi e o pensate di server
esplodere è normalissimo ci sta
ci sono periodi della nostra vita in cui
magari ci sentiamo un po più insicure se
di esser di non avere una forma fisica
perfetta quindi a natale ci sentiamo
chiaramente in colpa per aver mangiato
no se liberi in colpa e giusto natale
mangiare un po di più stare coi parenti
approfittare di questo momento dell'anno
ma come lettori riprendiamo subito il
primo punto e si chiude così il cerchio
basta mantenere l'equilibrio quindi
mangiate di più durante cenone il giorno
dopo non dico di età però mangiare sano
proteine e verdure in zuppe minestre
acqua acqua tisane purificante detox e
di tre giorni dopo potete riconcedere un
altro cenone o pranzo più abbondante non
succede nulla e state tranquilli
concludere il video con una massima
molto molto importante e oggi mi sento
molto motivazionale
tutto è buono e giusto di equilibrio
quindi va tutto bene senza esagerare
rimaniamo sempre nei limiti e godiamoci
i momenti senza farci troppe paranoie
spero che questo video vi possa servire
che ricordiate queste vacanze senza
pensare troppo
e infatti paranoie sul cibo e se vi è
piaciuto il video lasciatemi un commento
mettete mi piace se non avete ancora
fatto
iscrivetevi subito al mio canale e
seguitemi su tutti gli altri social in
sacal facebook e musicali e magari nelle
mie storie instagram vi farò vedere i
miei eccessi culinari di queste vacanze
anzi sicuramente la farò alla prossima
ciao